yunjin ryu coming off a terrific outing
last time out against this same orioles
ball club
two outs
wrecking ball little lazy pop-up
civilian into the aft advance makes the
catch
there is leave another base runner two
out walk not any damage
keegan aiken will get the start he's a
former second round draft pick in 2016.
as long as you make quality pitches
that one is hit again to galvez he's got
it in the hole and keegan aiken has
himself a one two three bottom of the
first inning
the former member of the blue jays and
freddie galvez
runs up to bunt sets it down
beauty
freddy galvez a bunt single and the
orioles have got a pair of men on base
against young gin ryu something that the
euros have had some problems doing well
he's tough to hit so think of other ways
oh yeah
just amazing how many guys get hurt
running
so he's most likely going to have to
leave this kind of looks kind of what
alex brickman went through foster so
it's going to be interesting to see who
they're going to run out there
since he's out of this game ryu steps
away from one there's a double play ball
right up the middle
for you looked like he was trying to get
out of the way of it and it was perfect
went right to
beau buchet then they turned a quick
double play as simeon flipped it to
buchet you know one thing that i have
noticed over the last couple of years
watching ryu how aware he is as a
baseball player
he just had the ability to make quality
pitches
there's a ball ripped past the third
baseman down the left field line into
the corner
timmy is headed for second the ball gets
hung up in that fence down there and he
breezes into second with its here out of
the double
that's four straight games now
precipitate with an extra base hit
bo grounded out to shortstop his first
timer
goes after the first pitch and rips it
into the alley and right there that'll
go all the way to the wall simeon is in
the score and bushet is hustling into
second with an rbi double and the blue
jays break out on top one to nothing
good to see second time through get a
gauge of that fastball first time
through it looked like they were
surprised a little bit that it was
getting on him
first sim in and now bo is able to
rifle that ball up the alley and right
center guerrero
back-to-back two-hour doubles for the
jays
swinging a high fly ball to left field
this ball's gonna go gun two-run home
run for bloody
on the first pitch make that nine first
pitch home runs
for guerrero from the on deck circle
just ready to hit
fastest in team history to hit 25 home
runs in the season 74 games
and here's another one how about
back-to-back home run so it took the
blue jays just wanted back to get zeroed
in on keegan aiken and they have jumped
all over in here in the third inning
back to back home runs for ta oscar his
11th home run of the season it's four to
nothing blue jays
just two hits they both came in
back-to-back order in the second austin
hayes and
freddie galvez
there's a strike called strike three
right on the quarter down and away
you know that was the pitch in the last
uh game that really bailed him out and
helped him
to pitch seven innings
ground ball
has it bounced up on him stays composed
makes the play three up three down
go play indy ball they'll continue to
play winner ball
springer gets jammed and lifts the
popper down left field line it's going
to be trouble it's in and out of the
globe of malayka
and espionage excuse me bechet said to
score
as springer
gets a little blooper then balaka had it
in his glove but it popped out and fell
slowly to the ground and it'll be an rbi
for george springer with two inherited
base runners one's already coming to
score and rambo hits one behind the air
to left this ball is carrying this ball
is gonna go get out of here gone home
run for randall gretchen
the third home run for the blue jays
this afternoon that's free run homer of
verandah
[Applause]
a one-for-two effort on the opener
thursday night and he hits this one in
the air
ariel on the run he's got real makes a
running catch right on the warning track
and mancini's retired another three up
three down inning
14 in a row retire by yunjin ryu
jimin drills this one to left this ball
is going to be off the wall one hops the
fence in left field espinar will go to
third sidion has his second double of
the afternoon and he hits
a line drive into left field that's
going to score a couple of runs here's
the throw to home play that is not in
time espinal and simeon both come in to
score it's ten nothing you don't want to
pitch the vladimir that's fine you gotta
pitch to teo and there's no place to put
them so you've got to come to in the
game
pretty impressive offense
good springer goes after the first pitch
and hits it into
that outfit that's a base hit here's the
throw to the plate cut off
as laddie slides in with the 11th run
another rbi for springer his second of
the afternoon
and the hits just keep on coming
pitch
he goes the other way that's another
base hit another run comes in to score
as hernandez crosses home plate with the
12th blue jay run
four rbis for grizzing
i think ryu's got going for him is it
those
shadows covering up home plate
severino lines this one into left field
it'll bring hazen throat coming to the
plate the catch the tag safe
a two run single for pedro severino the
orioles on the board in the seventh
good numbers with the bases loaden
and he adds to it mullins sends this one
to the outfield it brings in franco
it'll bring in another
two run
double for cedric mullins and it's 12 4.
that's going to be the end of the
afternoon for yunjin ryu
as the orioles get two in here in the
seventh
this is joe piams and we mentioned he's
not pitched since the 17th of june
against the yankees
[Applause]
becky ball hit in the air and this
should do it guriel the left fielder
moves underneath it and that's the ball
game the blue jays win game three of
this four game series 12 to four
to take a two games to one advantage
against the orioles